[Music]
there are few constants in League of
Legends eSports between roster shuffles
players retiring and legacies ending but
there are a few things you can always
count on na will always choke the
broadcast will always be delayed and
shocks
bringing fans across the world some of
the biggest moments the game has ever
seen from the goofy to the emotional
I'm really sorry to all my friends to
the savage way to check your solo key
records on jinx it wasn't fantastic but
it was created in a scared
shox is one of League of Legends most
recognizable faces but maybe more
importantly Shox has helped define a key
element of modern eSports broadcasts and
brought players personalities to eSports
fans this is her story
[Music]
if you Shox deported I was born on June
16th 1987 in Sint Andres Belgium now
known best as the face of the EU LCS
Shox didn't start her career in League
of Legends as a pro in the same way that
many casters and analysts do these days
in fact she didn't start as a league of
Legends fan at all since her first
gaming love was Unreal Tournament as a
kid growing up in Belgium shots played
plenty of video games but found her way
to Unreal Tournament UT was one of the
first massively popular online shooting
games with plenty of guns modes and
features to keep players interested Shox
for her part played instagib capture the
flag on clan prepare for your doom even
playing in several lantern iment s' and
winning a nation Cup with Team Belgium
the Nations Cup with Team Belgium so in
the Nations Cup Belgium would win and
actually in the euro Cups and all the
land parties I played my team would
always come in second to a team called
majestic 5 we would be in prepare for
your doom and it was kind of a rivalry
but after graduating from high school
and going to university to study history
she had to drop playing the game
competitively to focus on her studies as
her time at university was closing out
she began to panic shocks didn't feel
like she was ready for the real world
she felt like she needed more time she
didn't know what she wanted to do she
didn't know where to go so she decided
to stay in school I was very much
attracted to history side of everything
so I decided to do history for four
years over the course of us four years I
actually discovered that I liked to be a
sports reporter a lot more she moved to
Brussels to study journalism then back
to Ghent to get a teaching degree with
six years in school and three degrees
shox entered the working world but still
had no idea what she wanted to do you
like you're in the system where it's all
about studying and getting your grades
but you also have relative freedom you
know you get to kind of plan your own
time and then when that's over you know
okay am I gonna be a nine-to-five person
am I gonna have kids and you know I
don't know live remotely and and just do
my job and then I'll retire and all
those thoughts were just in my head of
like it is this for me what do I want to
do
she worked various temp jobs but when
she wasn't working shox was at home
playing video games and then an old
friend from her Unreal Tournament days
introduced shocks to a new game
[Music]
League of Legends wasn't new in 2011 but
it was still growing and it's pro scene
was still being built out
shox had never played a MOBA before but
she was hooked the competition the scene
it reminded her of her time playing
Unreal Tournament in her carefree high
school years you should try it it's fun
and I basically was really attracted to
the fact that it was just really fun it
it was a really good game to play with
five people to be on teamspeak and you
know it was a learning curve I was
really bad I mean I've never really been
great at League of Legends but it was
just so incredibly fun by day Shox
waited tables cleaned houses and
answered phone calls but by night she
was back to staying up late playing
games with friends and then one fateful
night
shox stumbled across a stream that
changed her life and it's in Hanover and
I think it was counter logic gaming but
it was like hotshot GG and same vicious
and all those people so really like old
school and I remember watching a lot of
that in my first couple of you know the
discovery steps of competitively this
game that Shox had been playing for
months now had a competitive scene just
like unreal dead but it was bigger in
every way tournaments were more
glamorous prizes were higher and perhaps
most notably the superstars were already
there she wasn't the best player in the
world but she knew in that moment that
she needed to be part of the League of
Legends community so she got to work
shox found her way to SK gaming who
hired her to write news about
tournaments and team changes it was a
small job but she made it into something
more her articles eventually got her a
job as eske's a lead editor for league
of legends and eventually into the role
that let her truly break into the scene
the host of summoners recap hey you guys
I'm Shox and this is the summoners recap
your weekly League of Legends news fix
and Jessica
hey guys and welcome to summoners recap
live from Austin Texas hey you guys I'm
Shox and this is a summoners recap still
your weekly League of Legends newscast
summoners recap was an early video show
for League fans looking to get caught up
on the scene it wasn't perfect but the
community rallied around it for both its
content and the personality behind it
French casting duo chips annoy French
chips shocked scared about League and it
showed which meant more people came
knocking at her door to get her in their
videos she was a regular guest on whose
league is it anyway a popular League
personality talk show and got a chance
to start traveling to events and
interviewing players at tournaments
around Europe hey guys Shaq's and I'm
here with our star player Ocelot who is
feeling a bit better than he was
yesterday but probably still not totally
over what happened those opportunities
got her a gig covering US eSports
tournaments for the cyber Sports Network
going to MLG Dallas MLG Dallas what I
will dominate jungler for Team Dignitas
Lone Star clash hey guys - Shox here for
cyber Sports Network from the Lone Star
flash - with after mu ad carry 14 fear
and the IPL finals in Las Vegas I've
been here since I arrived two days ago
and yesterday was like the training
getting used to stuff today and it was
really fun we played some arcade games
got to know a lot of new people so going
back home sharks as parents and
government were putting pressure on her
to find traditional steady work the
whole time she was still working temp
jobs while covering League of Legends
and she was running out of money
they weren't right in essence right
because I was like in that hybrid
between being a student in between being
a freelancer and
there wasn't really a lookout to a
steady job so things were getting things
are getting quite difficult I knew I had
to make a decision or I had to find a
job or I have to quit and leave
everything behind with the LCS on the
horizon things look great for players
but content creators shocks included
just weren't sure what it would do to
their space in December shocks went to
IEM cologne when one of the producers
approached her to do a quick interview
with a fan for the broadcast of the
higher-ups or people involved in the
broadcasting at ESA and they just said
you know you want to do this I believe
it was a fan interview or like a fan
check-in and then that kind of qualified
as a sort of a first step or audition
but I wouldn't say I completely didn't
realize it I definitely just kind of
realized that but I wasn't that savvy in
like business wise and what they were
trying to do so I just did a good job
apparently and that came back to me
later on yes L was gearing up to run the
first season of the EU LCS and just a
few weeks after that interview she was
hired to do player interviews on the
broadcast and she's never looked back
since joining the EU LCS broadcast
shocks has become one of the biggest
names in League of Legends she's on
League of Legends fan screens every week
whether it's for LCS matches and welcome
to the second day of our week two
coverage of the League of Legends
European LCS summer split all-stars I'm
official supporters that are on duty and
it's here on this stage that we'll be
crowning the winners of the 2013 League
of Legends all-star tournament later
today the analysts desk
[Applause]
it's actually really good even saying it
I'm not even saying it just to save it
actually really good
yes we're hosting world's welcome ladies
and gentlemen to the League of Legends
season 3 World Championship which means
she's also been there for some of
league's biggest moments shox was one of
the voices that kicked off the inaugural
season of the EU LCS marking a new era
of not just League of Legends but
eSports in general that same year she
was also one of the hosts of Worlds the
most-watched eSports event in history to
that point played in a sold-out Staples
Center
[Music]
I'm the official support that are coming
to you live from the Staples Center here
in Los Angeles California being there
effectively made shocks one of the faces
of professional league of legends she
was on every broadcast every fan and
casual watcher got to recognize her
between games just making one person's
day is the best feeling in the world
like when we have a show and then the
fans are watching and they come and
you're like can we take a picture or you
know can we talk to you guys for a
second like of course that's the coolest
thing about the job that you see you
just talk to these people who love the
exact same thing that you love every
single day there's no better feeling in
the world it also showed off just how
good she could be at adapting to bad
situations what it gave to start
everything off here in Europe
I mean people said that you guys didn't
look as good in the off season but it
looks like you've had quite a lot of
preparation
tell us about preparing for this huge
first matchup well we prepared it's kind
of you should have taken since there you
know it is nice from there her
personality began to shine through shox
has said that developing a personal
connection to the players she
interviewed was important and that
always comes through in the absolutely
brutal slams she delivers to certain
players I just assume that the really
good because they've always been good I
wasn't 50/50 for alternate yesterday
I'll tell Eve that oh gotta be honest
you guys got smashed by gambit there and
what did you take from that what did you
learn from that smash oh wait we have
bragging rights we won three games they
wanted points everyone's a winner and
outworlds 2015 shocks showed she can be
more than just the savage fun
interviewer she stood in front of an
emotional dyrus offering him a literal
shoulder to cry on while he gave his
retirement speech
I'm I'm really sorry to all my friends
that I let you down virus
it's only normal for someone like you
who tries so hard to the best to feel
this way in this particular moment but
all these people really genuinely
support you and there are so many people
who do because you've built up an
incredible career every single na LCS
game six times in the final in the NA
LCS five times at the World Championship
that can't be underestimated and they've
always been there for you what do you
want to say to them now it's time to
open a new book right now my story ends
here
I think there is nothing left to say you
have influenced the lives of so many
people and you will continue to do that
thank you so much willing to do this and
one more time for dyers this incredible
career and the fact that he was willing
to talk to us here I don't take anything
away from that moment and dyers the way
it was but it was definitely also a very
important career moment for me it's when
I also got a bit of recognition for
being able to kind of gel and in all
circumstances because of the way I
handled that interview and it just as a
fan because people often forget that we
are still fans you know we're viewers it
was awesome to be a part of you know
this guy who has an absolutely huge
legacy who is just opening up an ending
at the big biggest stage that exists for
League of Legends is absolutely
wonderful League fans can always expect
shocks on the desk or after a game but
her constant presence has helped define
one of the most important things to
League of Legends continued success the
players personalities they've been
clapping all along so would you like to
finish with a couple of words for all
the TSM fans out here
not as easy as I wanted it to be huh
it's not just lighting a bike faster is
faster you remember when we wanted one
of the first times you were going to be
on the desk and you're like I'm not sure
if I should do this and you've changed
so much since yeah yeah eSports has a
reputation for wooden players the
stereotype of your average eSports
player is that of someone cold detached
bad at socializing and while it's not
necessarily true of every eSports
athlete it's hard to convince people
they should be watching tournaments if
the players aren't given the chance to
overturn that stereotype that's why
shocks interviewing players between
games was so important in the early days
of the u LCS sure she was doing it
before hand but lols community was still
relatively small and her interviews
weren't raking in hundreds of thousands
of views but every one of those league
fans was watching the LCS and having
shocks after nearly every EU game
interviewing players to humanize them
did wonders for getting people attached
to the real people behind the incredible
plays these guys you see whenever they
win or lose you you can talk to them you
axe them sometimes behind the scenes how
they're doing and if they're alright and
you discover more and more step-by-step
but it is really a year-long process and
it took several years for me to get very
comfortable with people in general but
the fact that you just see them and you
can talk to them about a lot of things
makes you be able to break down a bit
more boundaries when it comes to on-air
interviews and that relationship with
the players is at the heart of what
makes shox so unique a couple of
interviews in a weekend at a tournament
doesn't do as much as a multiple
interviews every week with honest
genuine answers from players who are
willing to open up to someone who became
their friend as the seasons went on I
think that best for me was to use come
here and meet all the fans and obviously
see her pretty face every morning makes
it a lot better
[Music]
Wow you've gone already shop yeah she's
been in the scene so long at this point
that the players know her and trust her
but it wasn't just the players
personalities that fans warmed up to you
over time
they also warmed up to shocks herself
who through ubiquity and skill became
one of the biggest names in league but
thanks to her personality also one of
the most beloved listen loosen you hit
the pew the kick had more but it wasn't
enough to settle the score for ice
[Applause]
thank you so much guys there are a few
things that League of Legends fans have
grown to count on but the fact that they
count on shocks to bring them closer to
the players closer to the people who
seem untouchable makes her incredibly
important to the League of Legends
experience shox is on stream every week
and while she isn't doing as many
interviews these days she's responsible
for drawing League fans in it for making
people care about League of Legends and
it's superstars she's been there for
some of league's biggest moments some of
its most emotional moments and every
goofy headbang in between when many
people think of League of Legends
they don't just think about the
superstars they think about shocks who
brought those superstars to them thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button
[Music]